SPEAKER 1: The Google
Cloud platform channel
has hit 500,000 subscribers.
Thank you for your
continued support
in growing this community and
for sharing your excitement
and curiosity
around Google Cloud.
SPEAKER 2: This year has
been challenging for everyone
as we all try to adapt
to the new normal.
SPEAKER 3: Whether you're
pivoting your business model,
learning new skills, or
just hoping for a friendly
five-minute distraction--
SPEAKER 1: --we
genuinely want to help.
SPEAKER 2: Our
goal is to continue
to create useful and
inspiring content for you.
So if there's a topic you
would like to learn about--
SPEAKER 3: --please let us
know in the comments below.
SPEAKER 1: And be sure to
stay tuned for upcoming series
on data loss prevention,
best practices when scaling,
and Cloud Function tutorials.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you again
for subscribing and showing
your support.
SPEAKER 3: To show
our thanks, we
put together some
behind-the-scenes footage
of the studios that
we really miss.
Here's to another 500k.
[BEEP]
SPEAKER 4: Tweak 51, take 2.
[GRUNTS]
SPEAKER 5: 33 outro.
Take 1.
[BEEP]
SPEAKER 6: 1.
Take 4.
Deep breath.
[BEEP]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 7: Yeah.
SPEAKER 8: Asian.
SPEAKER 9: All right.
Cool.
I'm glad, because
implementation would have
been a problem for a minute.
SPEAKER 8: [LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 9: Like [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
[BEEP]
SPEAKER 10: Oh, we're closed.
Dang it!
[BEEP]
SPEAKER 11: [LAUGHS] OK, we have
a lot more dialogue in this vid
than I remember.
[LAUGHTER]
[BEEP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]